I will tell of the history of Gilgamesh
he who knows all that has happened and
has seen all the lands of the world he
who has seen all kinds of wisdom and
knows the mysteries and has seen what is
hidden he bringeth news dating farther
back than the deluge
he has traveled far distant roads and
became weary and now he has engraved on
standing stones the whole of the story
when the gods fashioned Gilgamesh to him
they gave a perfect form the glorious
Sun shamash bestowed upon him glory Adad
the terrible god of storms bestowed upon
him courage the great gods perfected his
magnificence beyond all of us terrible
like the great wild ball 2/3 God they
made him one third man of arak it's
great rampart he built and the wall of
the sacred iana temple the holy
sanctuary
behold the outer walls which gleam with
the brilliance of copper see the inner
wall which none might rival touch the
threshold stone it is from ancient days
goest thou into the iana temple yay the
dwelling place of Ishtar the like of
which no subsequent king or living man
might equal ascend and walk about on the
wall of our work inspect the cornerstone
and examine its brick work whether it's
wall is not made of burned brick and its
foundation laid by the seven sages
one-third for city one-third for garden
one-third for field and a precinct for
the temple of Ishtar
[Music]
these parts and the precinct comprise
Iraq unveil the tablet box of copper
unlatch the clasp of his brazen lock
unbind the fastenings of the hidden
opening bring forth and read out the
lapis lazuli tablet that tells of the
great hardships endured by Gilgamesh
[Music]
greater than other kings lofty and
stature a hero born in Iraq a wild and
rampaging bull was he he leads forth at
the front the leader he brings up the
rear a trusted companion he is a great
net who protects his men a thrashing
flood wave capable of devastating even
walls of stone a stone of lougle Banda
Gilgamesh is perfection in his strength
son two of the August cow noon son the
goddess Gilgamesh is tall glorious and
terrific
it was he who cut open the passes
through the mountains who dug the wells
on the slopes of the mountain sides and
who crossed the ocean itself the Great
Sea to meet the sunrise exploring every
part of the whole world the secret of
life it was he who by his strength alone
reached aterna past him the distant who
restored the holy places that the flood
had destroyed and who for the teeming
masses installed the rites of heaven who
can rival Gilgamesh who might like him
say it is I who am king
from the moment of his birth his name
has forever been Gilgamesh
two thirds God they made him one third
man the great goddess herself planned
the shape of his body
glory beauty and perfection bestowed
upon him by no timid his foot was a
triple cubit in size his leg half a rod
six cubits did he cover in each stride
his cheeks were flush with ample bears
and his hair was thick like barley his
beauty was beyond compare he was the
most handsome man on earth